so i've been watching this documentary  vitamania i've known about a lot of  different scams in the vitamin and  supplement world but i had no idea how  crazy it was and sometimes people think  they're taking something and they're not  even taking anything at all never mind  what the proven and unproven benefits  are of different vitamins and  supplements vitamania super interesting  i was watching it on curiosity stream  curiosity stream is my go-to for  documentaries it's better than netflix  it's better than hulu four documentaries  you can watch it on all of your devices  i'll watch it on my phone or on my  tablet when i'm on the go and it's super  cheap if you go to curiositystream.com  david it's 15 bucks for the year or a  dollar 25 a month and the link is in the  description